Avengers and the game didn't simply hit
the Disney Plus content shells at the
hundreds of other previously released at
Disney owned movies dead on the contrary
it showed up on the new streaming
service with a few added delights he is
or the never-before-seen end game
footage revealed by Disney plus the
death of Black Widow was one event
game's most tragic moments watching
widow and her fellow hero Hawkeye in
gate in an emotional tug of war over who
would sacrifice themselves to obtain the
soul stone was heartbreaking enough the
witnessing Widow jump off that cliff and
tell Hawkeye to let her go was
devastating but it could have gone down
a bit differently the deleted scenes
available on Disney Plus reveal
never-before-seen footage of Black Widow
getting shot by Thanos sister Tori
minions who arrive on for Mia and begin
firing at her and Hawkeye as she's
running toward the cliffs edge black
widow suffers several wounds including
one to the torso that leaves her
crawling across the ground in the end
that she manages to turn around and
shoot an enemy who was about to kill
Hawkeye then sacrifices herself as she
does in the standard cuts of endgame
less intense and unfinished ally 2
dansgame scene bundled with Disney Plus
sent us around to signing the silvery
quantum realm suits the heroes used
during their time travel missions in the
scene we watched as Tony Stark walks
into an area at Avengers HQ where
Professor Hulk is outfitting a crude CGI
mannequin of some sorts I am man
inquires about the status of the
thingamajigger
then admires how the quantum suit design
blends technology made by Hank Pym with
stark styling and a noggin bubble
courtesy of nebula and a spacefaring
friends oh as Tony calls them rings
Uranus with your true cop when professor
Hogg states that someone will have to
test out the quantum realm suit ant-man
says not it before Hawkeye steps into
the scene and offers to take the suit
for a spin on Disney Plus fans can also
find two deleted and game scenes focused
on Bruce Banner and the ancient one the
leader of the Masters of the mystic arts
who explains to banner how messing with
the Infinity stones can alter reality if
they aren't returned to the exact moment
in time from which they were taken one
sequence shows Hulk meeting with the
ancient one who's relaxing with a drink
in her hand and a pair of sunglasses on
her face in this kurta she explains to
Hogg that he's five years too early
and that dr. strange has no knowledge of
the time stone for which Hulk and the
Avengers are searching that deleted
scene ends with Hulk asking you the
ancient one s the second deleted scene
is an alternate take of the time-travel
explanation sequence here the ancient
one is speaking with Hulk instead of
Bruce Banner evidence that she didn't
knock Banner soul Aalto professor Hulk's
body to better connect with him in
conversation the discussion goes mostly
the same as the one seen in the
theatrical cut event game but the
deleted scene included on Disney Plus
features the ancient one admitting that
she was aware of Thanos his potential
for destruction but didn't do anything
about her since taking precautions with
fan OHS could have altered something
else in the universe easy peasy lemon
squeezy
a very interesting person
another never-before-seen endgame moment
revealed on Disney Plus it's a scrapped
scene that shows Earth's Mightiest
Heroes assembling in the trenches during
the epic battle against Thanos as
directors Jaron Anthony Russo explained
on the commentary track the sequence was
meant to be a building block for the
climax of endgame but the Russos wound
up abandoning the idea for a variety of
reasons namely that the moment was
missing narrative substance and wasn't
all that interesting an offshoot of this
idea the Russo's nose was to have this
pep talk and the mirror dimension the
parallel dimension in which
practitioners of magic can do things
outside the public eye easy peasy lemon
squeezy
the final additional scene snipped from
ends gained thus loaded onto Disney Plus
centers around Tony Stark in the moments
after he snaps his fingers defeats
Santos and Asami saves a universe and
sacrifices himself for the greater good
post snap he's transported to what Joe
and Anthony Russo referred to as at the
weigh station the meta physical location
where Thanos himself went after he
killed his adoptive daughter Gamora to
obtain the soul stone infinity war there
Tony meets a grownup version of his
daughter Morgan played by 13 reasons why
actress Catherine Langford at first he
doesn't recognize a young woman he's
speaking so but when Morgan Krebbs said
the two of them are pretty close
Tony realizes she's the same person who
often told him she loved him 3000 as a
child
Morgan explains are her father's
sacrifice words as she got to live and
grow up and be happy when Tony admits
that he's scared he made a mistake
Morgan says she understands
but she's very proud of him she also
assures her father that she's okay
without him I'm strong like mom and I'm
happy I'm happy we had the time that we
did yeah and that you were there for me
until you couldn't pay
of course the scene wraps up the way all
scenes between Tony and Morgan stark
should according to the Russos the Tony
in the afterlife scene didn't make it
into endgame because it felt like it
ground the movie to a halt
it saved audiences tons of Tears as well
but you didn't need the Russos to tell
you that check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite MCU movies
are coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and at the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]